PETER MANUELIAN: So how did the Gods appear?
How did they provide these
predictions and these oracles?
Well for the average
Egyptian, they would
have to wait until the statue of the
God was brought out of the temple.
So inside the sanctuary at
Karnak and many other places,
there was a statue of the God that had
to be ritually clothed and ritually fed
every day by the priests.
And then, on certain
festival days, the statue
was placed inside a
bark or a sacred boat
and hoisted up on the shoulders of the
priests and marched out of the temple.
And it's at that point when this statue
was brought across the river visiting
other shrines and other
temples, there would
be parades on either side of the Nile.
This was the beautiful Festival of
the Valley, or the Festival of Opet,
and this is when individuals
might approach with a petition.
Yea or nay, am I in
good shape, has someone
stolen from me, what about
this cow that I bought, have I
paid on the installment plan
correctly, or is someone
throwing an accusation at me, what
should I do, all kinds of questions
would come.
So how would the god indicate
what the right thing to do was?
The hieroglyphs talked about
nodding in approval or disapproval
and there's some disagreement
about whether the statues actually
had some moving parts and might
invoke their head a little bit.
That is probably unlikely.
More likely is that the statue in its
bark would be brought by the priest
either forward to say yes,
or backwards to say no,
or perhaps leaned to one side or another
if there are two competing petitions
brought, and this is how the God
would signal approval or disapproval.
And of course, I can't help
wondering about corruption
because all you need to do is bribe
these priests who are holding the bark
and holding the statue to
lean to one side or the other
to favor one case against
another case of course.
So oracles and predictions, the
individuals, the populace in Luxor,
or ancient Thebes, would be approaching
the god with very, very high hopes
to get the results that they desire.
The kings would be petitioning in
a much more private way, of course,
and these outcomes would be recorded for
all time in their temple inscriptions
to show that yes, they are the divinely
born next rulers on the throne,
they are on the throne
with all legitimacy,
or the decisions they've
made for this expedition
or that campaign were
absolutely justified.
So it's a good backup system
to bolster your kingship.
[MUSIC PLAYING]